[Applaudissements]
leroy coton règne en maître dans le sud
des états unis au début du xixème siècle
ou vers 1850 près de 4 millions
d'esclaves venus d'afrique récolté
graines des fibres blanche destiné à
l'europe
depuis 1808 le trafic d'esclaves est un
crime associé à la piraterie passible de
la peine de mort y compris dans le sud
mais l' esclavage reste les gars dans
les états du sud alors qu'il est abolie
dans les états du nord les états libres
la californie arraché au mexique se
joint aux états libres mais vient le
tour du cap chasse en 1854
alors que le chemin de fer progressent
vers l'ouest à washington le sénat
décide de laisser le nouvel état libre
de choisir ou non l'exclavage s'ensuit
une lutte violente entre esclavagiste et
abolitionniste ou déjà john browne
s'illustre dans le massacre de poteaux à
tommy et avec la mise à sac de la petite
ville de lawrence par les bords de
rafiots esclavagiste ça sent déjà la
guerre de sécession
c'est dans cette ambiance tendue que
james buchanan est élu président en 1856
ce démocrate est élu parce qu'il vient
du nord la pennsylvanie mais qu'il
soutient le droit des états du sud à
maintenir l' esclavage
on le décrit comme rigide et sans humour
il est et restera célibataire mais son
bagage et solide
james buchanan banques qui remporte
l'élection présidentielle en tant que
démocrate en 1856 et à l'époque et
encore aujourd'hui une des personnes les
plus qualifiées à jamais accédé à la
maison blanche il l'oeil le service
commun comme membre du congrès soit à la
chambre des représentants et au sénat
pour représenter la pennsylvanie et en
un ancien ambassadeur en russie en
grande bretagne il a également été
secrétaire d'état pendant la guerre
mexicano-américaine donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a beaucoup d'expérience politique
mais effective les choses ne se
passeront peut tel que prévu j'ai un
petit but qu'elle n'est pas s'esclaffe
hagist il rachète les esclaves de sa
soeur qui vit en virginie il les libère
mais à condition qu'il reste à son
emploi ce qu'ils feront volontiers pas
esclavagiste mai
raciste ce qui est assez courant à
l'époque après la guerre contre le
mexique il veut expulser de la
californie les mexicains cette race
bâtarde la case de l'oncle tom de
harriet beecher stowe est le livre le
plus vendu au 19e siècle à travers le
monde
la description des horreurs de
l'esclavagé fait des convertis dans le
nord est scandalisé esclavagistes du sud
apprendre à lire aux esclaves est un
crime certains tentent de s'enfuir vers
la liberté au canada par le fameux en de
groves road alors que des agents
fédéraux les captures pour les rendre à
leurs maîtres
c'est la loi telle que l'a subie le
grand leader et ancien esclave frederick
douglass et que james buchanan approuve
tout comme ils appuient et influences de
jugement dred scott qui affirme qu'un
esclave reste la propriété de son maître
même si les réfugiés dans un état libre
et aussi qu'il n'est pas citoyen
américain il faut pas sous-estimer à
quel point ils tensions sont vives entre
le nord et le sud sur la question de l'
esclavage et donc du kanun ne fait rien
pour pour pour calmer la colère
finalement des gens du nord il se range
derrière finalement cet avis et a dit la
cour suprême et donc ne vaut rien à voir
bien faire au cours de son mandat pour
tenter de mettre fin à cette pratique du
canal ne fera qu'un mandat comme il
l'avait promis il a même hâte de quitter
la maison blanche et la gestion de la
grande crise qui s'annonce un improbable
candidats abraham lincoln du parti
républicain un tout nouveau parti
fondamentalement anti esclavagiste et
élus en 1860 en profitant de la division
du vote démocrat entre deux candidats
cet état du sud sont immédiatement
sécession et forment la confédération la
grande guerre civile commence la prise
de l'arsenal de harper's ferry par
l'activiste john browne l'assaut des
marines et l'exécution de john brown en
sont le viol en prélude que
jusqu'à dire que la guerre de sécession
c'est sa faute responsabilité oui mes
responsabilités partagées
ceci étant dit au moment de la guerre
les américains sont rapides à lui
imputer la faute de cette guerre y en a
plusieurs qui parle alors de la guerre
de la guerre de monsieur buchanan il est
pendu en effigie dans plusieurs villes
du nord ont l'humain à l'humain
l'écriteau il est écrit traître dessus
parce qu'on l'accuse d'avoir fait
d'avoir fait collusion avec les états de
la confédération donc on va lui faire
porter le chapeau mais je pense que ce
sera un peu injuste de dire que c'est
uniquement uniquement de sa faute
n'eut été de la grande victoire
d'abraham lincoln chez big n aurait été
le dernier président de l'union
j'ai un petit but caennais souvent
classé comme le pire président des états
unis
ce qui n'empêche qu'on lui a dédié à
washington un mémorial assez grandiose
que personne ne semble contester
[Musique]